do you have an important physical coming
up then you need a doctor who will give
you results that are quick accurate and
will make you say thank you
you need dr. Ronnie Jackson he's got
skills and the experience to back it up
I could have sworn my cholesterol was
elevated but according to dr. Ronnie
it's within normal range thanks dr.
Ronnie dr. Ronnie said I'm 6 foot 3 239
pounds and I'm gonna live to be 200
years old just like our president thanks
dr. Ronnie dr. Ronnie said I'm a
perfectly normal and healthy 8-year old
girl
dr. Ronnie brought me into a room and
let me pet a bunch of baby goats then he
told me my cancer is gone I was
complaining of a sharp pain so dr.
Ronnie wanted to run some tests to see
if it was a ghost or a goblin it was a
goblin dr. Ronnie said I'm the tallest
person he just gave me this baby dr.
Ronnie said I'm a kite that's it he just
told me I'm a kite are you sure he's a
real doc I have a history of heart
disease in my family so dr. Ronnie gave
me these balloons I need to see dr.
Ronnie for a physical but he said that I
was dr. Ronnie and I should give him a
physical I poked around a little and he
seemed fine so I guess that means I'm
fine thanks dr. Ronnie thanks dr. Ron
scheduled appointment today
what even would not that
you